Colleen are you saying that Mike who we
had we featured one of our staff members
Mike Pearlman who was shot outside a
diner he described the experience in
graphic detail you're saying he is the
best-looking guy on the show yeah I
thought he was very good-looking
handsome I mean I'm older Robin who is
better-looking Steve no akima met or or
Mike Pearlman why do I have to be the
arbiter because you're a woman and
you're all I got
okay am I gonna a spread might agree
with this woman all right since you
Robin since you don't want to offend
anyone I'll have Chris Wilding I'm so
straight that I wouldn't recognize ya I
didn't even think Mike was that
good-looking I mean sure his pecs are
big yes he knows how to fill out a pair
of pants but I wasn't thinking in that
direction do you have you ever pondered
this Chris before this question yes you
want my ruling sure the best-looking guy
on staff yeah very simple you got
nowicki my met and I'm like Pearlman but
that might not even be the guy oh all
right that's true too who would I have
sex with that's right who's the hottest
guy yeah hottest guy not my favorite
person right but I will tell you think
about this guy this guy he's usually a
scumbag the best-looking guy the net
Walker yes that's controversial though
he has the best overall look I see Mike
not a good-looking guy well-built
you would blow Mike it's not you know
you'd probably pin you down give you a
great [ __ ] right of this I have made my
met is blushing I observe these jets
Steve very cute right probably give you
a good [ __ ] as well go ahead but if you
take it all into consideration the look
the swagger the way he comports himself
physically physically it's momento Fred
let mama come in and accept his award
give me some of the music like an award
show type sound and
and if you want to make a speech and as
your chance buddy ladies and gentlemen
the handsomest man on the show according
to Chris Wilding who is gay as the day
is long has been declared ladies and
gentlemen now Chris even today when his
hair is a mess yeah it's because he has
that effortless sort of hot look okay I
don't even think I'm looking my best
today but thank you very much and by the
way I've walked away from this title a
long time ago you you gave it up don't
want it I know but what do you want to
say I mean thank you I I don't agree
[Applause]
I know I said it's a heavy burden so I
would rather you give it to Steve
nawicki but for the moment I'm very very
fresh yeah when you're looking at him
now are you thinking about sex yes quite
honestly about blowing him until
completion Wow
completion in your mouth in my mouth
swallowing most of the love but man I
think that he said like my body and my
most people say like I'm a vomit inside
you know what I say that right I believe
inside you're a varmint doesn't like you
blow you and then I'd say really
disagree with you as a human being
immediately afterwards recently was
talking to some people and going through
the whole staff to decide which guy
would be your top or bottom and here's
he had a special term from a man he
wasn't just the bottom he's a [ __ ]
bottom boy mmm well I just won an award
you're pissing all over his answer would
be that what is will like they get very
flirty constantly in the very center of
your award would you please show Chris
your [ __ ]
I have to see your [ __ ] showing your
[ __ ] please all right go ahead but wait
a minute wait you were about to say that
will is a really good-looking guy Wow
you chose because it's not a special the
Mets a little younger and I basically
I'm a little more attracted to him but
oh my god I would [ __ ] will in a
heartbeat all right you know what I'm
enjoying this but we're running out of
drink his load
he's drinking a lot of lows